the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the summer chess
Classics I'm alongside vegan hello
everyone
yes sir it's good to have you here today
oh seriously right the three rounds just
went bing bing no right the tournament's
going so far
we have conspired amongst ourselves to
have a lot of fun we hope that you will
enjoy our coverage and let's start with
the standings and why some of the
players are having so much fun Vegas
what's happening group a so has El solid
who's Benjamin book who is two and a
half points and John Bergen pronounced
are only half a point behind them at
Nichols theater as well with two points
and it's a tie yeah big tie for uh
Second Place tell us about the standings
in group b Asha Chandra is playing a
wonderful tournament as a solo leader
and then Tai for second between lamasov
and Andrea Hong and others are fighting
just behind them absolutely perfect is
perfect tell us about the format for
these two events as we see the playing
Hall there
it's a two 10 player round robin
tournament with 19 minutes for the first
40 moves with 30 minutes for the rest of
the game and 30 seconds increment
throughout the game and the schedule is
pretty been uh straight forward
tell us about it we have rounds every
day today is the round four Saturday
and then I will
a woman August 10th and maybe if it's an
accessory we can have playoffs
play us and tell us about the
about the what our viewers can expect
today again we have great pairings and
awesome players but our key matchup for
the a group is pronoun versus bogey it's
gonna be a very exciting game I'm
excited absolutely our tournament leader
against his nearest rival let's just
jump into that game uh pranav as you can
see I love those
cameras uh from the playing Hall I
really like it when I can see the
players and and they're getting into
their games it's good to see them as
well exactly we get to this position and
the imbalance is pretty clear we have on
uh White side of the table we have a
majority on what we call the center King
side on black side of the table he has a
majority on the center queenside so it's
a big fight who can put their Center to
work now from White's point of view he's
missing F4 you need to put the pawn on
F4 let's see how things unravel
[Music]
no quick question before they played
Bishop H4 would you have played G5 I was
actually considering ah I was thinking
why not fire well I know why not you
already told me correction I told you
please don't move backwards exactly uh
Bishop H4 was Benjamin's just uh F4
takes takes and after Queen E2 Knight D7
pretty much we've caught up with the
players we can expect a pretty uh
straightforward ideas again what you
want to do whenever you have these
majorities is you want to be the one
putting your majority at work exactly
from Black's point of view now I
appreciate that this move is not
possible but from Black's point of view
he would love to Anchor the night on B3
and play C4 putting his majority to work
also one more important thing to notice
is that Benjamin only has eight minutes
what yes
has 41 minutes it's a huge Advantage
yeah maybe Benjamin is comfortable with
playing like all the time you know time
traveling something but still it's just
hard I would just say I'd call it
complicated yeah I call it what it is
bad time management full stop end of
story uh tell us about the pairings for
the group b Group B is getting exciting
every day but of course our key matchup
for today's Chandra versus lamasa who
are the two leaders Chandra is leading
um with full point of it's time for
second restaurant and I think this is
going to be a very
exciting and kind of nervous
nerve-wracking day yeah absolutely let's
jump into the yeah let's jump into that
game and this comes out of an English
and I've always liked these positions
but white I've enjoyed playing them and
I have never let me repeat myself I have
never
put my knight on E1 in these positions
like that is for me just a kind of a a
shocking move often at times I have put
my knight on E3 I put my Bishop on B2
and away we go I've also played D4 and
oftentimes looked for the possibility of
playing Bishop to F4 so as we were doing
our rehearsals coming in the studio I'm
having my coffee I'm figuring things out
I see 91 and I just think what on Earth
is going on
I think it's pretty straightforward when
you I mean this night by the way just
think about the tour that this Knight
has made
I mean but I think the idea behind 91 is
you want to play F3 and you want to
recapture with the tempo yeah it's I
think it's modern engines which suggests
this kind of like
91. I've seen something so similar in a
time to play F4 right and take over the
center well let's see how the chess
engines are working 91 and again I
shouldn't argue with perfection I mean
after all akshot has one his three games
in a row and
well
here we go let's just stop for just a
short moment we've got three Pond
islands versus two on the other side of
the board our predecessors would say
that lacks better just stop you know it
I think strategically they are better
yeah and uh let's catch up with the
players as they've reached a very
imbalanced position again these Pawn
structure positions uh uh calls for all
kinds of tricky lashing out ideas uh
Knight E5 E2 E4 you can see there's
going to be a lot of
um
it tactic tactical issues and I think
that's actually true for both sides
exactly but if we're going to change
some of our pieces with black and put
Knight on e4 yes I think my position is
lovely lovely yes 19. so many weaknesses
right and uh well we'll keep an eye on
this uh the players are fighting they've
been fighting hard what Bingham are the
players of fighting for
so the prices of the tournament a is
first place six thousand dollars second
place four thousand and third place
three thousand dollars and from the four
fourth to the tens we also have price uh
prizes for all the players with the
total price fund of twenty two thousand
dollars and tell us about the price
point for Group B for Group B first
place is four thousand dollars second
place is twenty two and a half thousand
dollars third place is two thousand
dollars and the rest of the tournament
participants participants also will get
prizes with the total prize fund of 14
000 very nice and as we were coming in
the studio we were stunned as Alexander
Linderman with the white pieces had
already lost by the time we're sitting
down
we're like what the heck happened to uh
Alex Slenderman again this is a player
Linderman who's played in U.S national
championships where you need at least a
2650 rating to even be considered so uh
having a very bad tournament true that
takes takes okay all you know all very
very standard stuffs thus far Queen C2
Bishop G5
it all looks like we've been here before
we know one another very well Knight
takes D4 again one of these uh positions
greatly in Balance White's queen size
structure split upon 95 isolated but
very very importantly for these types of
position it's a little bit awkward to
break this pin in principle you don't
want to break it with G5 you're likely
going to play either Queen B6 or queen
D6 in order that you can play Knight to
E4 so for the two Bishops I'd say white
is for choice that is a strange move
okay uh Queen whoops that's what happens
when you uh when you click the wrong
button Queen B2 okay I I think his idea
was just to play Queen B4 and exchange
of Queens right also maybe to release
the Rook uh you know you want to go Rook
A1 Rook pardon me Rook to E1 without uh
necessarily hanging the pawn
um I'm not happy I'm not comfy with that
move at all uh something like something
happened in the opening I just don't
I just don't want to have these
positions right right after 10 months
well that's strong but I I'm just saying
that for for me Queen B2 is not the joy
let's just let's just have a look see
imagine I play the move Bishop F5 and of
course it's as obvious as the clear day
I want to take and I want to take again
you do not let me emphasize that one
more time you do not want to play the
move G5 that would just weaken your F5
Square so uh for the moment the bishop
needs some protection Rook d8 what do
you what do you reckon I'm thinking
maybe
because I want to bring them
make sense makes sense takes takes I
mean here
[Music]
oh then you take on F6 never mind
exactly that's why you don't play with
this summer
um I'm just I'm not a fan of Queen B2
maybe it's not a bad move maybe it's uh
in fact all been played before it's
amazing how deep the opening preparation
of the players is today Knight B3 look
at this okay let's change your night on
day for tonight on A5 I don't like that
decision either now I think black's
troubles are behind him because you can
see that it's going to be easy very easy
for black to break the pin once he plays
Queen E5 and Rook C8 black might be
thinking hey you know I I I'm in here
maybe Linderman's idea was to just
equalize and make a draw again because
you remember he made it
maybe he's feeling that his tournament
is not going well and he's not you know
like right to move right mindset to play
the tournament okay and he missed
something I get that I really do I
genuinely I'm with you 100 on that but
sometimes
when you sit there and say I'm playing
for a draw
that's when you don't have the proper
mindset in this position I would say
it's even let's be fair but if I had a
choice if I I really did have a choice
I'd probably slightly prefer black only
because I already have possession of the
open file and maybe who knows you know
maybe on a good day
I could set up some pretty nice threats
okay Rook C8 F3 Queen back whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa everything is going wrong
now this move just loses it's just
losing move chat it's just a blonde and
Bishop H3 and the intended Queen B2
which would nicely defend everything now
white was going to meet Rook C2 with
Rook F2 but now you can't and it was
over just like that wow very bad showing
by yes I feel bad for him I do too I
mean sometimes again
uh to our audience when you play chess
there is no question about it you're
going to lose a lot of games stand in
line you deal with it you lose games but
here's the key
the games you want to lose is where your
opponent plays well if your opponent
plays well beats you in a good game tip
your hat say Well done when you play
like an idiot
that's unacceptable that's a huge
problem right right so I knew that I
became a good player when my opponents
had to play very well to beat me yeah I
wasn't just blundering a piece
blundering uh walking into mate no they
played a really good game I felt good
like hey you know you had to play a good
game next time I got to play better but
this was not and also probably he had to
keep play disposition take on C2 and
take on H3 just to you know just to
break his Bishop yeah I know it's yeah
of course lost of course of course just
to wake himself up a little bit you know
exactly just kind of show us a little
bit of fighting Spirit you know I
thought the same thing and I saw this
check and it was kind of really
off-putting for me if you play King here
unfortunately yeah
I mean okay now's a good time to resign
yeah
you play a few moves but I'm with you
but I think his mindset coming into the
game I just want to make a draw and
let's get it over with and then when he
had this losing position his mindset was
not I'm going to resist with my uh best
by the way Brandon and Amman also made a
draw list
let's see what happened here so again
we're not even getting into the players
we're getting into uh the uh results
um yes sir you seem happy about it no
result wait wait thank you all for
coming we had a very nice day
hard work hard job time to enjoy the
weekend
a two
I mean I think that everybody and his
brother or sister in our case is played
Knight C3 Queen in E2 bring the Rooks so
when you play C4 you don't rush to play
A4 and when you play A4 you don't rush
the place C4 either you get one of the
two in right okay let's okay and for a
penny and for a pound boy that you know
it's uh it took the World by storm the
alpha zero program and I have to tell
you when I saw the alpha zero games I
knew there was alien intelligence
because the way the computer played was
so extraordinary and one of the things
Alpha zero was doing was putting the
pawn on H6 and the reason for that is
you know it really makes the king
uncomfortable
not sure
Leela also loves loves the Harry the age
4x5 and as as you can say in manual
H4 and a foremost right a lot more
nowadays than it was before exactly well
I'm not a big believer in the you put
the pawn on H6 okay potential I see it
more as a liability than an asset
Brandon has his own views obviously
maybe Brennan's engine has its own
reviews
by the way you know did you hear that by
the way after the move C60 did you hear
the cheer
oh yeah that Bishop on a a the moment
the moment a month
I heard that Bishop that Bishop said
Thank you praise the Lord that that
Bishop was suffering the moment that
Bishop opened and
um I remember there was a terrible
terrible game
terrible terrible terrible game that
happened between
Anatoly karpo and Joe latier where Joe
lattier
this picture from the A8 there was a
there was a white Pawn on C5
during the game someone is choking you
[Laughter]
and it was pretty bad look that game up
for just you know for the joy the fun of
uh I don't think it's fun it wasn't
defended
it was great fun C5 let's go Knight A3
okay this actually uh makes a great deal
of sense brand business if you're going
to put your Pawn on A6 you might as well
put your knight on B5 so you can harass
the
A7
well an answer prevention's worth a
pound of cure takes takes takes takes
I must say I really like the way black
has handled his business here it feels
like they are better like Rook is
working Bishops are and Quinn's coming
to a tour yeah the bishop is very nice
both the pardon me let me uh uh say but
I find both Bishops to be very very nice
uh the move Knight G4 okay that has
tactical of course yeah I mean uh
basically black is saying you go ahead
and take my H Pawn we're probably gonna
trade one another's uh h-bomb for E5
Bond but guess what queen H4 movie
mentioned is we got here rookie
I was about to say queen H4 is Black's
business so why aren't
this players
uh yeah they they
and uh by the way you have a very famous
uh sacrifice uh double P sacrifice we've
seen these patterns I'm like why aren't
you playing pure Knight on G4 play Queen
H4 well let's take a look there because
he obviously he didn't uh do this
probably after H3 he couldn't find
anything because if you played it yeah
yeah absolutely
and then suddenly I can take on H7 and I
don't have any problems right I'm Pawn
up and show me what kind of attack you
have exactly
um
yeah that's that's exactly it there's no
attack there
um but in this moment I'm just I
apologies for pausing
um
Queen G5 we just wanted to kind of take
a gander at this exactly F4 yes that was
a key question
I I wasn't sure absolutely after Queen
H4 probably I can play G3
G3 Bishop E4 Maybe
okay
um
a little bit right yeah uh because it's
one of those things where you want to
play a rook lift in a really uh nice
world but you there's no real clip okay
uh a draw there let's again yeah let's
again take a quick look at our Marquee
matchups as we left it we had seen the
move uh Queen B4 by samyan as he says
well with straight Queens
um also one of those other things that I
was going to say about the queen trade
we've already discussed it on previous
broadcasts when do we want to trade
Queens we want to trade Queens when our
King's vulnerable
um full stop that's a very good time
that you want to trade Queens the other
one
the other
um situations when you want to trade
Queens is when you have a better
structure
sure or your opponent has Dynamic play
yeah right and just dynamically that's
the situation and that's the situation
so Black's King is is fine so he he
black is not motivated uh to trade
Queens because his King is under attack
he's motivated to trade Queen because of
the dynamic nature of the position he
knows that if he could just take all the
Dynamics out like you said a moment ago
trade a few pieces
control some squares then the structure
will be in Black's favor so let's see
how akshat is handling his business we
just saw the move C5 okay once again I
did like your suggestion of Knight E4
but C5 is on the board
C5 is on the board now let's just try to
take a Zen it makes sense right I want
to take on B3 and take on D4 okay and
create even more weaknesses okay now it
asks you a question what do you want
right I'm not sure so I'll take a pass
I'm going to play the move King h1y in
my mind's eye I'm really let me play 95.
I play the move 95. you may take twice
and take with a check in other words my
King has the potential of being more
vulnerable on G1 than on H1 so I kind of
tucked my king in turn it over to you
what was it that you wanted to do uh
what if I take on D4 still take on D4
still okay I was dreaming
that now you're taking yeah now you're I
wanna maybe I should take on B3 you take
with the a pawn and then take on D4 as
you wish
from princess's Bride As You Wish okay
and we've got it but now
hello I know I know Knight C5 I'm just
trying to play against B4
and and uh I come from the Pacific
Northwest I know and they love grabbing
phones no there was a guy from the
Pacific Northwest and his name was James
Harley McCormick dirty Jim
and dirty Jim as I was growing up he
would say to me we played these Blitz
matches give me your pawns baby
but he had this cranky voice almost
Darth Vader like voice and uh in this
case I don't know I love your I love
your emo King H1 yeah just uh I don't
know it you know you may you may say
Okay King H1 Rook a E8 you may make the
argument my Rooks a little bit better on
E8 than on f8 now go with you on that
absolutely maybe I can even play B6 and
prepare but like my point was that maybe
lamasov is trying something immediately
you know right that's why we have to try
and see well let me just refresh my
board I'm going to go quickly to the
game of Andrew and then I'm going to go
back to action times are they a factor
unlike our Benjamin Bach game yeah wow
absolutely because there are only 18
moves in and akshat has 15 minutes and
lamasa has eight minutes
[Music]
I know how can you spend all your of
your like time of in 18 months exactly I
love it when my opponents are in time
trouble I just absolutely like this is
for me it should yeah well it's a couple
of things one of the things I always
thought that when you play your moves
not quickly but when you buy you you
play your moves responsibly that you're
showing me that you have confidence when
you sit there and burn 20 minutes
still undecided you're showing me or
telling me you have a lack of confidence
so I've always thought of the players
who move slowly as being insecure in
their position by the way Bishop G3 on
the board
um
action is thinking
once again I can only imagine that the
reason for the move Bishop G3 is that
your the open or half of an f file you
really want to play the move Knight E5
and put pressure on on F7 but it seems a
little bit useless too because I'm not
going to move my
f693 as well well wait a minute hold on
so he says you know a moment there you
were telling me you were ready to play
Knight E4 a move by the way I think is a
very good move so if the move Bishop G3
stops you but still you're not putting
any pressure on F7 because Queen on B4
can any time check on going on B3
correct correct
um
another just uh insight and again for
the audience just keep this in mind
you have all of these books on tactics
right when you raised on the tactics and
you knew all of the the the various
tactics pin skewers forks and so forth
and so on so we've got all of these
tactics that are spread out in front of
us
percent
of all Tactics come down to one thing
one thing only double attacks
double attacks are only possible when
things aren't protected
so I have this running running thing
going on in my mind Anatoly karpov was
fantastic about hiding his Pieces away
he would play a move like Bishop H2 just
that karpas pieces were untouchable
right when you play the move Bishop G3
to my way of thinking you're took a
protected piece a piece on F4 that was
nicely defended and unprotected it
making it potentially vulnerable to a
double attack
I don't like Bishop G3 uh let's go on uh
and I want to go to the other oops
excuse me I'm going to go to the other
um group group a bringing up the game of
Benjamin Bach and surprisingly today
group a is playing longer than broker
three no results right yes very
interesting uh we left it not too far
from these these whoops once again uh
apologies
you know probably by the end of the
tournament I will not learn not to hit
that particular case
I got a lot of mistakes still to be made
uh the move Rook C8
um
okay
wow uh this is tough for me because
I it's a very very responsible moment
and
um I don't know exactly how to say this
other than it's very important that in
these positions you use your majority to
my way of thinking
I don't like that move very much I like
very much A5 A4 that's what I was
thinking and then later when I make the
move C4 it really comes with extra uh
bite I have a feeling he thought after
A5 probably they can play B4 but the
thing they don't understand that Rook
comes to A2 yes and yes sir as you said
you loved her up there uh even at the
cost of a pond this could be one of
those really really dangerous moments
that you don't want to deal with as uh
as white again it just feels like black
is the one who's putting his majority to
use okay rookie Rook a C8 is not the
worst movie it's like very natural and
then your first instinct when did
someone attacks you is to protect right
exactly uh by the way Benjamin who is
considerably behind on time is invited
to rep petition he played the move Queen
G6 oh that's how he gains something F6
okay and uh pranav
said you know what I'm white I like my
position I'll put my Bishop on F2 your
turn Queen E7 uh this is a clear
indication for me that Benjamin is
floundering he doesn't really have a
plan he did everything okay he put his
Queen on F6 he put his Queen on G6 and I
put his Queen back on the ace E7 is
essentially wasted three moves
unfortunately that's the situation when
you don't have time yes again if you if
someone is threatening you something you
just try to do the basic reaction
reaction which is just right and
protecting your position pieces and now
he doesn't have a time to come up with
anything he well he didn't and in fact
uh he could have
happily wasted his time with putting his
Pawn on A4 a position where well I I
would recommend
if the pawn were on A4 once again a
moment ago I was I was
beating the drum for The Outpost night
on B3 I could put my majority to work
and let me just refresh my board because
yeah Queen E7 what is pranav's time is
24 minutes yeah so I wonder if he's
gonna spend time one yes it's just one
minute four seconds I wonder if you if
pronounce is gonna spend time to come up
with something which puts some problems
to Benjamin or he's going to play for
his time because many young kids make
these mistakes right yes exactly you try
to play for your opponent's time exactly
a quick question for you if you were in
pranaf's shoes what move tell me the
candidate moves that come to
I was thinking that I either need to
push G4 G5 somehow which is like Bishop
E1 so I can protect Knight A5 keeping in
mind the bishop just came for me Bishop
like keep in mind the bishop came from
D2 I know I'm
not but like you put it to have to
what's your idea like well he was
protecting at the time there was a queen
on G6 protecting the pawn so you're
thinking so if he's going back the
problem is that if you play Bishop E1
and black is gonna play a queen and F6
right okay right and then maybe I have
to protect the G3 Pawn with the king
king F2 Rook H1 my second idea was like
I tried to play Knight G5 but first I
need to most probably play E5 but the
the idea
yeah
exactly that's why probably he put his
Bishop on F2 so he can control like E3
Square somehow but I don't know what
Bishop on F2 is doing still I would
never play that move hopefully
and then most probably his idea actually
is to play before basically
yeah that's the only idea but I I'm not
fan of that idea okay uh just your
assessment in principle is white a
little bit better is black a little bit
better I think white is a little bit
better considering the time a situation
clock situation and now he's preparing
actually he doesn't want to attack or
play on the king sides or Center he just
wants to do Rook C1 and before try to
protect against it okay like you have 40
seconds
that's what you do right uh if you play
A5 I play Rook fc1
that was the whole idea and then I can
take on D4 that was exactly the tactic
that uh pranav is uh betting on now he
needs to play Queen D6 I guess well the
you have to do it a move earlier he did
play Queen D6 like yeah that's the move
on the board
I think it's somehow kind of funny and
again I'm just sorry I will just uh
refresh because if I've got this right
Benjamin's last four moves it's been
with his Queen
he's just trying to get the position
until 48 years but how I have to go well
yeah again I I see a little bit of
floundering here by Benjamin yeah he is
our tournament leader but he doesn't
feel if he's gonna lose this game it
will be like totally on him because of
the the clock yeah uh I just wanted to
say that in this position after Rook C2
one of the things that uh you always I
find it uh
gratifying is defining the structure so
one of the things that white might do is
white might play for E5 you might play
G4 G5 if I play the move E5 and you play
the move uh F5 for example
I play what I would call
defining the structure I play G5 the
hardest moves to make and then harder
suppose to like to react to right so you
you kind of feel me here what I'm saying
is okay I'll put the pawn of course on
H6 but here everything is
chained together
I like defining the pawns I would
structure upon me I would find myself
drawn to the movie E5 and drawn to the
move G5 of course you you're you're more
than welcome to uh do this type of thing
in fact
I would like to say I welcome you you
won't react to that exactly you I
welcome you to play on the queen side
yeah
because I feel that this Pawn is
essentially you're not going to be able
to keep it I will you you don't have
enough forces in the position to defend
the pawn and you're playing on the queen
side once I do win the pawn back once I
stops you from going G4 G5
I'm happy but okay uh there's so many
games going on and we have focused on
this one uh to me a heavyweight matchup
that's for sure that's a very
interesting matchup actually to locals
by the way and these two players boys
and one of them from San Luis right
rivalries forever that's it uh not best
friends forever but uh rivalries
it looks very safe for both players I'm
going to say that this ending even
though you know our principles have told
us
um protected past Pawn on all of that
good stuff in Truth uh the act of pieces
the good blockade I want to say King
will be on E6 should be a draw let's
just continue Mishra our newly crowned
U.S Champion U.S junior Champion pardon
me hasn't had a good tournament
is suffering as well
I saw him yesterday ronak after the like
round it was tragic yes
uh things are getting interested
oh it's the home key you know on on our
uh other broadcast I do I'm not kidding
they have it taped
yes I can't
I've done it so often he taped it it's
like I wonder if I mean handcuffed
okay 94. uh double-edged position what
do you think here some crazy stuff is
happening I mean that isn't a little bit
interesting to sacrifice I like Black's
position yeah he's having some fun isn't
he but we need to just get the Rook
somehow out
by the way Bishop H4 to defend the and
by the way we caught up with the players
tell me about the time
it's uh seven minutes for a behind you
for around like 14 minutes and you can
see how nervous everyone here is that
he's shaking his
yeah Mishra at the board by the way that
was what we called the Bobby Fischer
Shake because Bobby Fischer was known
for the for the knee going
no I'm upset I have never played him
uh by the way sometimes depending on the
stage sometimes the stage
a little red a little rocky wait did
other participants ever complain about
of course of course Bobby complained
about them
it was a deal uh by the way uh tell me
uh what Mishra wants to do after the
straightforward Queen H3 gift me upon
he did not play it I think I saw a rook
come into the game
I think that's what but well let's
figure out Queen E3 I suppose his
intention and then he doesn't want to
drop E3 yeah he doesn't want to drop the
pawn but I was thinking hey you know I
got a pawn now for the and then just go
back right and then you know keep the
active pieces he did not do this let me
emphasize he's trying to activate all of
his pieces before attacking but I wonder
if it's too late
you know too slow exactly
um rookie eight it does have the benefit
of setting up a a wonderful
um discovered attack so basically if it
was his move he would play Rook Queen E3
Queen D3 Queen F4 Bishop G3 now I can
Techni right yeah that's right that's
his idea the other idea was the
immediate Knight G3 but the same point
now here's my question can I get away
with Rook here and answer probably not
right
am I getting too many pieces I was
curious and I think the answer is no
well well I can take King G3 Queen E3
King G4
are you mating me that's the question
but if you do this King H2 Queen E4 ah
cage you know for some reason that's why
you need to check it yes
that's too many pieces that's why your
queen E3 first probably is more crucial
which one is instead of taking on the on
City okay
uh sorry takes rookie too
we're missing mate
why are we analyzing this planet
oh how can we yeah sir that's such a
shame can we cut this
it's live it's terrible and terrible I
mean I mean they're laughing at you
our producers are like laughing at them
oh my goodness you know whatever what
happens when I'm with you yes sir your
voice calms me down maybe I feel like
nothing is happening in this position I
I took it away uh we had whenever we
make a mistake on air like that we have
a way of dealing with it good morning St
Louis
that was a mistake uh Rodney Dangerfield
would be very very pleased very happy uh
Rook E8 on the board let me just refresh
my board I'm just gonna go back and
forth quickly
which means this move rookie eight has
really
um I think he figured that's who he left
too is a Checkmate
unlike ourselves
C2
but now I only have a rook and a minor
yeah maybe a pawn or two but yeah I like
black I mean the queen is stronger we
gotta come out I mean right now four
minutes and he needs to figure out what
to do it's I think a huge threat is
Queen E3 but Knight G3 and plus most
probably if he's gonna move somewhere
you know not that nice if he's gonna
misplace his pieces it's gonna it's
gonna be just bad for him right they're
gonna be even more threats in this
position
it's a very tricky move he's reaching
he's he's suffering he needs to make a
move right he's uh okay he has six uh
not six ten minutes ten more moves right
let me just play a devil's advocate then
in this case so I'm going to play Rook
to G1 if it's my turn I'm telegraphing a
threat right and then after Knight G3
now we don't have the Checkmate too
right but we're gonna take an F5 uh
we'll go Queen C5 just
now
that we know and if you play rookie too
[Music]
Queen H5 I should be meeting you I'm not
100 convinced that's true
maybe you are maybe you are not but look
at me sure he's
he's doing his hand
[Music]
look deep free I guess
33. that's very exciting
I don't find myself to be a fan of this
move I'm a fan of drama chess drama 63
oh my God oh my gosh that's okay
okay
what's the story on Knight F2 I mean I
would love probably he just wants to be
Quincy fight
but aren't you like but I'm uh no but
I'm an exchange up right as long as oh
you're gonna lose the exchange instantly
right
okay but that's what was the question is
who's better
I mean I'm an exchange up you've got a
great attack clear so uh uh but he
doesn't have the time to understand
who's better he just needs to neither
player right Rook D3 on the board and
again we're going to just look at this
13 minutes to three minutes uh let's
let's keep going because uh Nicholas
versus John
oh my gosh it's like one of those
positions Nicholas we always plays this
like messages crazy positions I mean
double Rooks on the set on the second
rank but look at this it feels like he's
attacking but I wonder where he's
attacking too like roots and queen like
where are they going well what's your
destination well he's gonna play G6
right his destination is f8 I think he
just wants to be tricky at some point
play like Rook G6 then Queen F6 ideas
like that yeah but so for night on D6 is
great that's right protecting everything
and the night will drop back to if we
imagine a position where we've made the
beautiful leap of faith Queen F6 the
Knight will drop back to E8 and protect
our check meetings where uh that's why I
have a question where are you going okay
well I'll tell you I want to go to G6
and then just take on G6 or Cafe correct
but are you meeting me I hope so
yes sir hope is not enough well it is
um
a plan
a prayer
this is what I'm
hoping to do this is what I'm trying can
I take on E2 or should I take on H6
immediately kind of Welcome to do both
I'm I'm not I'm not you're not taking my
route yeah I keep your
you're so generous yes sir I must say
people historians will call it heroic
others will
will call me generous
kindly yeah it feels like what well at
least I just want to say that if I'm
white so you are going somewhere I'm
playing you have a destination and like
let the chips fall where they may I mean
that's what's on my agenda
also not for nothing but again if you
play A5 just the kind of thing that you
want to I was thinking of that idea used
to work when I fall right yes yes
Queen E5 and you'll want to take
um yeah and and snip the pawn so it is
incumbent upon John
to come up with a plan here and I said
Nicholas has only one minute
I
I would expect I would suspect that much
of Black's defense is are based on the
Move Knight D6 to E8 just to protect
that uh very important dark Square
weaknesses that exist what would you
play after 98
well you're going to have to join the
Prime Membership if you want the answer
to that question we just don't give it
away you know
okay uh let's have some fun
in for Penny and per pound right
G6 let's go
uh now
okay I'm not sure I'm doing it the way
the best way yeah so where are you going
was this bishop takes I know quintex and
queen H5 2019 YouTube but you tell me
what you think what you find the most
attractive
and again uh yeah you want to Checkmate
everybody's business is clear
Bishop F7 yeah
yay
went back
to John well essentially what that means
is John is finding
White's attack I didn't bet and go back
he didn't I also I wanted to go back up
4.4 he did play 98 by the way he did
play here we go immediately Rook H4 was
played no see you don't just give away
the exchange
why not why not especially when it's not
here
look I am very generous with my
opponent's pieces by the way you just
[Music]
Rook H4 in an instant uh uh I thought G6
was on his agenda Rook H4 it just it
seems nice but after Rook see it back I
don't think like after episode
I don't think
um just help me out here uh what does
what is the purpose of this move like if
I
if I play B5 I I don't care I'm just
throwing out a movie can I play G6 right
now that was okay good you're you're
you're you're you're you're
anti-conscious and take on G6 and then
gotcha okay so we do have a threat we do
have it because seven should be the most
Queen E7 fighting for the dark squares
that looks like a very decent Mall yeah
and then also I'm not giving you to play
G6 for now you're taking away the G6
opportunity and I I also want to take on
F6 so most probably Theodore wants to
play Rook at four back you want to take
on F6 yes and after GF so but the
problem is
are you meeting Masters here I don't
know but I mean queen F4 is scary at
least probably I should have never took
it but
I mean I'm greedy but boy
I like the night on E8 The Rook on F6 is
my friends always say you don't care you
just take I take it uh okay very very
exciting A3 is
a Greek and take on probably F6 and then
Queen C7 ideas and rookette three is
also coming and keeping keeping contact
with G3 I like that uh quickly let's
just jump into assassi uh versus Aram
um
interesting this is a little tough
because
yeah this is not a a familiar looking
setup for either player
I like the bishop because I feel this
Knight is just a little bit offsides
like imagine I go Knight D2 Knight E4
and I'm not suggesting for the life of
me that you trade the knights but if I
do get a dominating Bishop on e4 versus
a knight on A5 I feel good yeah that's
all I just feel good and by the way it
seems like five positions yesterday on
the board and
I like Sassy's position here we do have
a result by the way darush versus Ilia
it's not a surprise we're gonna jump to
the
I think this is so funny we're jumping
to the game of pranaf versus Benjamin
way before Benjamin played Rook A8 to C8
I said he should play A5 A4 put the
Knight on B3 and then play for C4 I
think he listened to you only after
moving his Queen four times
I mean we left it I am not kidding he
still has something
he moved his Queen four times in a row
by the way the Knight came back to H3
kind of supporting this uh what you had
mentioned like I mean but you don't do
that like that you put your Bishop on D2
and do it and if you took your all all
of your pieces to the queen side you
played there
but White's pieces the Rooks most
especially I find them
to be targets like you're playing on my
side of the board imagine just just
imagine you had your Pawn on G5
where do you want your Rooks exactly not
on the C file that's why like and then
there is something that's uh that's
mentioned in some old books
your Bishops can indicate which uh like
which side of the board you want to play
in right Bishop on D2 you could like go
for the king side by the way we do have
this position after G3 I find myself
favorably disposed to Black's position
because I don't think this is a threat I
like this tension that black has and in
my mind
if I can play the move C5 C4 you're not
playing F5 and you know you're not
you're not killing me there so for I'm
not going there anywhere and then I made
some weaknesses on the king side as well
as white right if I'm trying to open the
position and take on H6 you can play
King H7 Rook G8 or queen G6 and suddenly
I'm under attack as well and like
putting the knight from after it to H3
not the brights idea I would say not the
brightest now we have a key moment it
takes takes so a key moment is you have
two options
you can capture and try to play the move
Queen A6 to take advantage of the pen
the other thing is you can play for D3
the way you play for D3 is you can play
excuse me a move has already been played
Benjamin who is in time trouble you can
play Knight C5 with the idea of playing
uh D3 He took
back and I you know you you kind of
close your eyes and you say I have to do
this if if I move my queen I think
blacks yeah doing
well and then now black doesn't need any
time to win the game exactly Rook takes
C4 so it's on the board now
um what did I say about unprotected
pieces
yeah yeah
so whenever you have unprotected pieces
on the board you're always vulnerable to
double attacks a move like Queen E6 will
force you to give up the C file move
like Queen A6 let's just look at Queen
A6 for a moment Queen A6 Rook C2 is
there any trickies
yes yes yes
now here yes yes but I don't have to
take it
no you have to move the Rook of course
yeah but look at
this I'm on your doorstep no the idea is
to take on B3 and then the playroom
the idea is to play Rook C1 your idea me
to play Europe E3 but let me introduce
[Laughter]
almost probably still over right but
there is okay what I'm saying is
Benjamin power to him has uh absolutely
his agenda his agenda from the start had
been let's play on The Queen side where
I have my trump and you can play on the
game it's just upsetting yeah so you
were playing Black pieces in this game
and I was white and then look what and
then it turned around and you know we do
have this position by the way and also
our seven minutes and so secure and they
decided to make a draw I was kind of
happy with Sassy's position probably he
didn't something happened let's be very
fast about this because we've got so
many uh they just made a repetition he
didn't see how to improve his this
position most probably
just say have to if we didn't have the
knights the absolutely his position is
clearly better but it was the knights
most probably how you can improve well
I'll tell you uh right here
uh instead of the move Rook C5 Knight D2
is it 92. so virtually any move you play
I want to play Knight E4 I want to trade
and what I want is the result of the
night still stock on A5 versus a bishop
on on e4 it didn't happen too many
exciting things are going on let's jump
to the John Burke game for a second
because we've got action all over the
place for Queen D6 you didn't go Queen
E7 Queen D6 he's eyeballing the G3 Pawn
look look look look look look
immediately G6 takes
whoo
Bishop that's why you play Queen E7 I
guess
Bishop E5 I see this is terrified I'm
terrified
you should be terrified
97 that was the only move can I take on
G6 simpler Queen F6 that's careful there
is a rookie to check don't forget about
it King G1
Rook takes no there's no choice if you
this is winning this is winning Rook AJ
check no no no no Queen
you're absolutely right
good morning St Louis again again but
this one now no here's the problem
rookie too take it roquito
I'm all safe and you're not safe
oh my God Queen f8 Brooke h8
that that is a disaster that is a
disaster
I mean that's why Queen E7 felt like
right again I'm just going to refresh my
board again apologies for this uh maybe
you're missing something
this job yeah yeah
this is it uh F takes uh Queen F6 on the
board oh my God and 30 seconds 30
seconds versus seven minutes
here again I'll try to get in some very
educational tips
eight by eight boards 64 square board
that's our Battlefield
what's the best diagonals for the bishop
the long diagonals because the long
diagonals the Bishops are at their
Zenith when you looked at this position
some time ago and if I could tell you
what magic you could do take that bishop
and just put it on E5 exactly it's so
much more effective and we were talking
about putting the queen on E5 and I
cannot believe John Burke was like 15
minutes encourage this and queen F6 uh
John is going down quickly let's go to
Benjamin box because again we and after
Queen F6 uh John Burke had to resign it
just had to resign yes uh by the way I
feel bad Manchester was a game
you know again I
we were talking about that in the car
the other day for me I love the
Brilliance who doesn't everybody loves
the brilliancy and it takes two to tango
right yeah I can't be brilliant if
somebody isn't forcing me to play really
really good moves so for me when the
game is over and it's a brilliant game
I'm just really really again if I lose a
game where I play like an idiot that's
the worst uh by the way Benjamin
position everything's flowing except for
the time uh after the move uh hold on
like three more moves and he'll be fine
pranab didn't want to play Rook C4 Queen
A6 we've kind of looked at he put the
queen on G4 he wants to attack he's like
your pawns don't bother me intimating
he's got a threat I don't think so uh
Benjamin said I don't see the threat
you're welcome to take on H6
no so I suppose the idea is if you did
take on H6 I would just defend the
threat
with Rook F7 or maybe I don't know G6
but still it's good to tuck it no well
it's kind of strange I'm threatening and
then we should be three okay he played
Bishop E3 at once and again because of
the tricky clock situation how many
moves do they have to make we have three
more moves two more moves I believe and
we've got 30 seconds we don't have the
the picture of the players a camera shot
um
[Music]
and he's looking at the clock and he's
coming
he's just trying to make a move just
Queen E7 queen queen G6 okay what
cream cheese
okay so what did you do and then I'm
attacking obviously the Knight is
hanging no obviously The Rook is hanging
okay gurukshi too she wants to take on
e4 that's the idea
precisely
what what do we say about the double
attacks
loose loose
pieces fall off yeah it's like what did
he play he played Rook G2 Flint Wilson
used to say loose lips
he had to take on H6 before he played
Bishop E3 it was very important maybe
that was a crucial moment but let me
just uh again this is our Marquee
matchup as two of our tournament leaders
he's reaching to E4 Pawn
take it
here we go Queen takes E4
grabbing the phone
now if he's upset he's like oh
Well it can't be that simple like but he
does have that look of like
uh you just took a a Fang
out of the attack Benjamin just needs to
do one more move okay that's move 39
again
six then you're just taking with a check
that's the problem
King H2 what's the problem just to
protect each dream okay salon and Rook
F7
and how are you it doesn't feel like
this is
you're just not breaking through well I
should take on G7 right the idea is to
play Queen H5 and Tech sex Queen G4 pack
it's just so slow I've gotta hold on let
me just uh refresh uh Queen takes E4
um
I'm not a fan so just can I play a
rookie E1 that was what I was going to
say I'm not a fan that I have to take
a long a quiet move but I I do threaten
and D2 is not a it shows that you're not
threatening Bishop D2 but you're just
protecting the bishop exactly
hmm
well the game and maybe let's play a
rookie won he did
did you no I did you did I did that's my
our analysis you prompted me sorry yes I
know on the contrary I was the one uh
being extremely supportive I like rookie
one
but you you still have to prove
that after a move like Queen F5 if you
trade never trade never trade never
trade you win your Pawn back but I got a
feeling
you're not gonna play for him like
Checkmate yeah
well but it's kind of it feels all very
very shallow uh yeah
too strong too strong too strong agreed
um so let me just
he has two minutes yes
42 seconds for Benjamin exactly this
moment it's on move 39. Kiki moment as
these two players who are tied oh pardon
me Benjamin leads but uh pranav is a
half a point behind absolutely yeah yeah
okay it must be
very stressful to grow under one minute
for 10 15 months no I don't know how and
I can't imagine he repeats it every day
for nine inches
no no no I cannot uh we had players in
the United States who lived by on this
Cliff's Edge this precipice of always
you know going down on the clock the
things that there are tournaments when
you cannot avoid time travel
because you are not ready to play and or
maybe you have some other issues during
the tournament but like playing your
like chest style like as lifestyle is
like that under time pressure it must be
very bad oh very bad it happened to me
one time one time only in my career I
was in a U.S junior
us junior Championship and I was playing
against Perry Young worth
and I had less time I had five minutes
against maybe eight
and somehow I looked at the position
looked at the position the thermal clock
and I had 10 seconds on my clock it's
like where did the four minutes go it
just went and I went bam
and uh
he immediately reacted because he saw my
time and he blundered because of the
reaction of my time sometimes by the way
Queenie for and I've just been told I'll
Sean lost his game against Andrew Hong
which means Andrew is keeping his at
least tie for a second or maybe
depending on akshat's game he might be
the leader of the tournament yeah
because Andrew has been having a really
fine tournament plus two two and a half
out of three with akshot at a perfect
score Queen takes E4 and G takes HC
sacrifice what are you doing
these these they were good players at
one time in their careers so let's take
a look Queen you you don't if I'm in
Benjamin's shoes especially with seconds
on the clock you just take it and you
take it and then you think because it's
the last movie it's check it's
interesting he H2 and let's just see
what are we missing we might be missing
something I think it's just a pin on the
southern NCAA that's why he's just
gambling on that it's temporary and it's
awkward but or can can you can you
cannot you gotta go night too far no
Queen
foreign
[Music]
why he's upset
wait or did something happen King H1
interesting
King H1 so the difference is that now if
you play Rook F7 Knight G5 Knight G5
there's no Queen takes F4 check but the
still Queen takes F4 no
[Music]
wow uh it looks like Benjamin again
we're gonna kick you out as we but uh
our first interview of the day but uh I
want to say you've done really great
thank you except for the missing the
mates yeah you missed that too hey wait
a minute
okay so uh we have a Time control uh
We've made time control that I want to
say and uh pranoff is not happy he's
lost his bishop and you can see his
reactions there on the camera uh a very
very tense and Wild game occurred here
and his decision not to take on C4 may
be very very very costly but in the
meanwhile we're going to welcome our
first guest our first victim sorry
Nicholas
Jump Right In congratulations Young Buck
well done
and uh Let's uh bring up the game
what have I done you know I really
enjoyed the interview yesterday so I did
everything I could too yeah right you
wanted to jump back in now
the second I'm just having a show again
welcome to
uh you defeated John Burke and we were
looking at the game right
it was probably very bad for me
throughout but
yeah so I knew this line existed there
was okay a recent game Matlock of
vitashek probably
um but yeah Bishop B4 is probably the
most accurate and move 10. okay so all
of this is very standard I uh I funnily
enough yeah this is I actually looked on
the board I looked at the book yeah the
the the the theory there's and I was
very surprised that this is all standard
there's also some game
um Bobby against yard and Van Forrest
which went D4 instead of D4
uh so G5 G5 D takes E4 and instead of D4
I'm pretty sure yeah yeah and I suppose
you this is also playable yeah but D4 I
thought is more critical okay
so this is all your prep so yeah there's
Bishop B6 Bishop B4 and Bishop E7 but I
thought
as far as I can recall Bishop B4 is best
okay
so yeah actually I spent a bunch of time
here I'm not sure even though you
prepared this
I have prepared it at some point but I
didn't remember all the details so I'm
pretty sure Knight F3 is also moved here
but I didn't wanna
risk
um not being absolutely certain yeah
okay
uh you chose H3 takes takes now even
though you slowed down did your opponent
also slow down at this point it looks
like he was also sort of familiar with
the line but
there's no way he I have always done
this
there's no way he looked at it before
the game because I've never played one
C4 okay
she was also trying to remember probably
everything
um so you're kind of reaching more or
less some kind of a prep it's a mess
though how do you evaluate this mess I
wish I could
an honest man
tell me when you
things are critical like so you actually
here I thought it was being smart with
Queen B5 yeah after 95 sorry
like it's like the nuclear key and I
keep getting it wrong it wrong you
thought you were being smart with Queen
B5 provoking A6 because I was looking at
Queen before yeah
without provoking Asics and then I
thought she could play Knight C4 okay
Rook af1 right
93 Knight E3 okay and during the game I
thought it could take on F7 okay Knight
takes F1 Rook G7
hello signature Bishop G5
but now he has Queen B6 so by provoking
it has pawns on A6
exactly yeah so that was the clever idea
okay so you were you had
seen quite some uh in-depth calculation
and now you got the position you want
and you're looking forward to playing
this line where he doesn't have to shoot
but he kind of surprised me through E6
pretty much you to play G5 yeah now my
Bishop looks trapped a little bit yeah
nice move
yeah and Quincy Fire is probably very
bad because I
as soon as I moved I thought you could
play Bishop E6 and pick up a Tempo
another way yeah and actually he's also
threatening Knight C4 and my queen is
just stuck there
so I mean I didn't say anything better
than Queen A3 here oh my gosh I'm not
sure if and you're on the back foot yeah
no question about it I mean there are
some Bishop takes E4 tricks but there's
Rook B5 for example I don't know
oh oh things have gone wrong let's speak
oop I was about to say let's speed up
but I didn't want it to go that fast
um Rook B6 Rook C6 probably ill-fated uh
at this moment did he decline a
repetition yeah I mean I would have been
pretty happy with the draw there after
trap and trap and tuning your own Bishop
okay let's go fast
because we when we came uh what happened
to us is we saw these Rooks yes
I think and we thought you were in
trouble how was your feeling I mean much
like yesterday I was in severe time
travel right I had one minute to make 10
moves or so so I was
um
kind of not sure what's going on right
actually I think taking my
my two pawns there which is Xerox kind
of helped me because all of my movies
are sort of easy after that point yeah
okay so here we got to the point where
he played the move Queen D6 yeah we were
looking at Queen E7 just with the sole
idea of stopping you from playing G6 was
this your main move yeah Queen E7 I mean
I was gonna play Queen F4 probably but
then I thought Rook takes C2 yep and
then I yeah I can also play Team three
one but sorry
he snagged another Pawn no yeah yeah so
I have to take but then
no no I mean sorry into the king G1 you
have to take that's what you were saying
yes and then King julonna said Queen B4
probably wins for him right wins yeah
we are on the same page uh so we think
the move Queen D6 is a bit tragic
because now
yeah she your heart skipped the beat
because suddenly you're in the driver's
seat he probably missed this whole idea
of relocating the bishop to E5
and
flat yeah uh this was a nice touch uh we
thought Rook takes E6 uh very nice and
queen F6 and you're hiding on H3 I
almost feel like by the way before
playing queen of six no how close were
you at three seconds but I I agree yes
but I was also looking at through gate
check oh no because that was what my
first thought and then takes queen of
Santa is probably Rook C7
kind of holding on
yeah sure
yeah or I mean it's yeah it's also
lights out probably
uh wow okay uh kind of a reprieve then I
mean it wasn't your best game but it was
a nice finish yeah I got the job done in
the end exactly
Nicholas thank you for coming in thank
you my pleasure all right be good good
luck and we have results coming in hot
and heavy as uh Nicholas has just
defeated John Burke but we've got uh
more victims
as Andrew
has won a very nice game today against
elshon
we you know people are going to talk
Andrew you we we're we're dating you're
coming in all the time congratulations
thank you today
um tell us what happened I think today
was an absolutely Wild game um I
personally had no clue what was going on
um but you know sometimes things break
in your favorites as they just did for
Nicholas in this game today uh tell us
when you're prep or let's stop because
right now you're in a variation which
Anatoly karpov made famous the zeitzev
and it's a very very sharp line and yet
it's not popular outside of them it's
only our profit so how well prepared are
you for the size
um to be honest um obviously you can be
dishonest no I I didn't really prepare
much going into this game because you
know I I sort of figured Alex I'm gonna
play whatever he wants to so it's just
no point on looking too much in somehow
I I didn't recall too much about the
side stuff for some strange reason so I
was just playing on my own at this point
okay so uh right around here more or
less I'm gonna say that maybe Theory
stops should we kind of take over uh
some of the outcome of the opening you
you've got your Central Pawn Duo so
you're kind of happy about that vague
King side attacking chances but what
what was your feeling
um I thought it was maybe I slightly
preferred white because I think um
you know little pieces look about
balance but um so I've slightly more
space with the center so right I thought
my only goal was to maintain a slight
advantage and I can play as long as I
maintain it I can play for however long
I say you want to I just know rush to do
anything drastic okay let's see how the
game continues would be it kind of a
useful move sometimes when you don't
know exactly what to do protecting your
pieces
on B7 needs a little protection okay uh
both sides are happy Rook A3
idea that you might want to sneak across
I don't know Knight H5 A5 again one of
those useful little moves and now the
position is much more defined so you're
you're clearly cruising on the king side
and you're saying to your opponent do
your worst you're going to put upon a
pardon me you're gonna go Bishop A6 and
spank
um how's your feeling right about here
here I was um
I had no clue what's going on
again we have our honest man in studio
everybody uh Queen C7 King H2 yeah I do
I'm just gonna throw everything at him
yeah yeah the kitchen sink is coming by
the way no G1 if if that's not a
telegraphing I don't know what is
here we go and he's basically
challenging you right
oh that is an intriguing
um decision okay an intriguing decision
out there yeah I think he was afraid if
he let's say if you'd tickle the road
then this is very dangerous day and
night H5 uh Knight H5 no night F5 uh say
F6 just uh
bingo
and the point is um yeah uh you can play
that's Like Queenie song yep but at the
very least I've got four two dropping
The Rook
um looks bad yeah it feels it looks bad
feels bad uh there you go all right uh
he therefore he took with the pawn
pardon me uh Bishop H6
well somehow you've achieved yeah
Heroes quite confident because yeah
you're willing to strike yourself that's
what I meant I have Targets on both
sides yeah exactly
it feels
it feels like things have definitely
gone in your favor and you still have
those Knight F5 uh the lingering they
haven't gone away
well that's in your face you're
threatening Knight H5
I think the last mistake because uh you
just picked up oh
I think this is the most accurate
because yeah what was the most accurate
Queen H6 ends the game on spot clear
yeah kierog three F5 takes an E4 and
here D6 cuts down oh
and oh that's sweet otherwise if Knight
takes D5 then I can take here yeah
there's no time to play this because
we're G7
um but on the other hand if he trades
then there's a killer blow at the end
Bishop B4
removing the defender also blocking this
oh
ouch
that I think ends again so Bishop E4
that's very beautiful too yeah that's
why I quit H6 is the most accurate I'm
sure other moves are winning let's say
like take and yeah
no no no no no no I like I like Queen H6
a lot
and once again uh the game
that's I mean there's some very nice
moves that you played here
that looks very D6 very attractive
dude
that was good that felt good that was a
good game yeah I guess so yeah I'm sure
the guys I'm surely can feel a little
disagree I know but uh before you run
back to your room and get spanked by the
computer this was very nice I appreciate
it yeah well done thank you thank you
Andrew good luck with the rest of the
tournament wow nice nice game there and
thank you to Andrew for joining us as
well
I'm gonna have to deal with being him
again you know how it goes guys this is
tough this is tough and a game we didn't
see uh bacon was the game between Justin
Wang and Luca did you see that nice game
yeah actually wasn't that beautiful
Andrew did bang bang bang bang bang
which game and then we checked other
games too yeah so uh look at this game
is quite interesting he somehow got out
of like uh D4 opening still got kind of
a D4 okay French position isn't it a
Queen's Gambit accepted
looks like a queen's game you know
versus four or two versus two looks like
a Queen's Gambit accepted
I'm trying to it
imagine he's winning the game and then
it's again yeah for those of you who are
joining our broadcast let's shame on you
but uh begum and I I have been trying to
encourage begum to consider the Queen's
Gambit accepted as a very solid reliable
defensive apparently you guys can win by
it
she's saying I can't win the game is
black and I want to win his black and
we've got
quite the Donny Brook going on but my
first thought is I love Luca's position
Luke is having a bad event but this last
move Queen D3 in my mind
defines the fact he's much better he's
much much better he's
well obviously he's threatening the
bishop but this Knight on F4 is
tremendous I don't think you can play
the position with the Knight on F4 if
you take however
uh
the fork means that you you're probably
going to have to hope against hope that
you can save this position earlier
actually Justin's position was very good
almost winning earlier it was yeah it
was then Luca took over unfortunately
but both of them are having a bad
tournament so far so of course it was
obvious it's going to be a huge fight
they must want to win right
now a local turn the tables and it feels
like look he's gonna get this game
wonderful wonderful uh let me uh turn
the attention and also it's the only
game left in B in the B group yeah
otherwise all the results uh would be
determined to winners in the B group
we have uh Lenderman losing really a
poor game where he just blundered badly
very very early and Andrew hung winning
uh an impressive game also akshat ended
his game
the interview is sharing the time for
first there's action right actions yeah
akshat came in today's uh round with a
perfect three for three but his draw uh
opened up the door a small little window
that Andrew crawl into and it's going to
be a great game between them
I don't know yeah yeah yeah or Hollywood
script writers who are all on strike
uh Bishop G3 this is the move I'm not a
big fan rookie eight we were saying no
now
there we go in the end of today when you
are right I don't like it
well don't call me Nostradamus but
you know by the way if I could play Rook
takes A7 but you know the move that
scares me terribly and you know where my
king would rather be yeah just saying
just saying
[Music]
very nice move I like that move a lot
by samyan as he's prepping so many weeks
worse he's like if your Tech was the
king I will play Knight day through
Bishop C5 all all day yeah a converging
right oh nice look at this action where
the night is coming now check okay
okay so it gets one Pawn but
these Bishops
pardon me this bishop is really con
doing a great job
wow okay uh
what a what a imagine playing this
position in time scramble that they had
what a fight Bishop uh
uh check it out uh two-piece boops
that's the nuclear button I know I know
I know I'm gonna that's your producers
uh put the nuclear tape do not press on
hold
uh
yeah it was they had like two minutes
versus a minute or two
I see and they did the players did
transpose into a bishops
wow wow what a what a draw what is a
fight
I love seeing such games me too me too
it makes me play chess it makes me want
to bleach it exactly which is a rare
question
by the way I mean uh you helped me out
here uh I'm appealing
to our audience
I don't want you to become a lowly
broadcaster like me a lowly I want you
to become an over the board Champion I
mean thank you big big big big Champion
so you know I want to encourage you uh
I'll be getting this text from Yasser
every day like do something U.S
Championship women's championships
coming up you're feeling good you're
getting yourself right so far I'm not
commentating so far
all right uh Justin and Luca we think
that Luca is in great shape here and
should be winning after the move Bishop
Jesus just say another day another
suffering so far it's against his face
see this moments makes me
want to stop playing yes
I feel like I'm hurting someone like
emotionally right oh uh no this position
looks terrible and Luke has uh winning
let me just go to the other group
because somehow more things more
interesting things are happening and
Nick Nicholas by the way in this game
against John Burke Nicholas thought he
was really in trouble that he had messed
up and that that move Queen D6 by John
uh tossed away the game Sorry what were
you about to say can we check
I'm just curious absolutely what are
they up to
oh because this was a game that we
thought black was doing pretty darn good
we saw the move Rook E8 and we didn't
see a very good answer for Mishra he
eventually played Rook D3 and I was
saying well what about Knight f g two
which was but Knight F2 was only played
after the move Rook C8 got included
huh interesting I wonder if he could
take on C8 and sacrifice the queen
you know with the King song yeah Queen
never mind Queen B2 is coming as well
just a second let me show you what you
might have missed
yes sir
just a second let me catch up with you
in case of your queen takes B2
you just love showing my mistakes
it's not that convincing
because you do have
I do have I saw that too but Queen D4 is
coming okay but what is the body count
you've got two Rooks
but there is no chance that I'm winning
this game that's that no that's the
problem right no if I have something
better I should do something better than
Queen C8 and my idea was like but I
already thought at this point that life
was better
so uh you know trying to bail out
finding those variations oh that's a
nice move by
um
isn't it terrible we are doing way
better than me as well uh interesting so
basically this queen G one I think that
that was a great find yeah uh because if
you recapture then after Knight takes
your toast Queen takes B2 is on tap
right I think that's what I mean robots
missed a great
I like it I do too that I mean sometimes
we're all in awe of these players when
they win beautiful games and things like
that you know what really wins
tournaments great defense great defense
you can win a lot of tournaments by not
losing games to be honest I like the
funding is special I have only moved
just like easier to defend an attack
okay we've got Bishops of opposite
colors on the board that's funny that
both of the sides they don't want to
exchange the Queens ronak was like
Bishop E4 I will play and then here
abhimanyu is like okay let's grab the
pawns no exchange right uh we've got up
to the players nothing really exciting
obviously uh black is going to play with
the extra Pawn for as long as he
possibly can and uh I wouldn't be
surprised if if
um Mishra successfully holds the game
let's go to our Marquee matchup when we
left it uh a Time scramble at the end
Benjamin Bach
successfully made the time control and
not only did he make the time control
but after the move Queen takes E4
we thought he was winning King H2 on the
board Rook F7 we can't play the design
front office listening to me King H2
uh well what to say he took and he's
hoping I just wonder why he rejected
King Adrian what's his idea so he's
literally doing what I told him not not
to play uh but okay uh Benjamin should
have quite a number of defensive
resources here let me just but it's not
easy right and then plus Benjamin is
going back to his
old friend time scramble yeah yeah
for example couldn't H4 and I'm
threatening Queen d8 and then Queen h8
and your knight cannot move B3 Knight is
kind of useless so far Rook on Rook C6
Queen H4 sorry continue what we're using
my idea is to play Queen d8 and queen it
means that you cannot leave the eight
Queen d8 and queen h8 uh it's not that
simple copy that so I think the idea is
maybe Queen
E4 in order to
match you but you always fall into 95
right at one moment
and the idea is just 90 G5 somehow we
they I really have the idea that we got
we got something like this right where
yeah we've got the two better version
though
for black yeah yeah because at the end
of the day we both felt that this Knight
and this Pawn were too strong I would
rather not to have Pawn on it for
yeah the exposed King you could get your
Rook check so I'm saying Queen H4 looks
like uh pardon me Queen E4 in order to
go Queen H7 looks like a an important
defensive resource uh well the problem
is that maybe I can
I can put two
so I can play
like Rook F1 so the idea is that you
want to play Knight G5 after activating
and queen if you play Queen gh7 I wonder
if I can just play King James
Rook G7
series Rook G7 and then just King uh
Queen E6 and then Knight G5
I'm threatening
can you really play uh so slowly why not
I'm just a pissed off
Knight D4 looks good here all right
give a 94 here Knight D4 you know I was
beginning to like the position so much
for black I was even starting to think
of Rook to G8 and wondering if I can't
you know Checkmate you I don't think so
yeah I wouldn't be that it would be I
would because if you open up the file
let's go
I would love to have that's why I don't
need anything of the file I was trying
to Checkmate you on the rookie G2 is
coming so I thought you wanted to take
on a G5
uh sorry uh we're looking at a position
with Queen E4 I think it's a natural
move because I agree with you
wholeheartedly I don't want to follow a
victim to either a queen DHS or queen
hhx I'm leaving my Rook here you
mentioned Rook F1 as an idea of prepping
right yes and what did I do I was no we
it just said for example right yeah yes
Queen H7 now that pins the night
so that provoked you uh to think of the
move King G1 so that you get to play
Knight G5 on a good day
now here I've got so many good ideas for
black I'm I'm a piece up I know as long
as you play like Knight D4 and then
consolidate it must be very
just uh I I like the move Knight D4
principally because it takes away these
squares for the queen I have a feeling
for nav is just bluffing yes he's just
sitting like that I'm like
you know sometimes when you're bluffing
best is to be as stoic as possible
to sit there you know is it I sacrificed
it every I sacrifice look at my
blueprint this is my masterpiece and if
you sit there go and
they're terrified that throws an
important Town yeah let's take a look at
the standings with one of the
tournaments completed
absolutely group a Nicholas Theodore one
game and he has three points Benjamin
book is still playing it means that he
might jump to the first place if he can
grab this position piece up and for now
he has two and a half points elianiznik
he has
uh two points two points yeah one of the
one of my takeaways with Ilya I don't
understand why he wins a lot of swisses
but he's Ultra Ultra Ultra solid in
these Classics he's like he's kind of
happy to draw his way out of first
continue please and John Burke he he had
a disaster today
who is Benjamin box still Darius and
Sushi Kiran they decided to have a quiet
is still fighting uh
Indian Grandmaster
very very nicely done and tell us about
the group b stand
grumpy standings are quite hectic here
Andrew Hong won his game today and his
time for First with action genre who
drew his game and they both have three
and a half points by the way let's stop
and think about that three and a half
out of four that is crazy that's
beautiful uh me uh the singer Meatloaf
said two out of three ain't bad three
out of four is great continue
and Lamas is just behind them with three
points and Armand mikelian also he's
drew his game and half a point behind LA
massef and Brandon Jacobson also drew
his game and he has two points alsoers
are so far suffering a little bit but
suran won his game which was his first
Victory against Slenderman unfortunately
and lender man is having a turbo
tournament so far and elshon lost his
game against Andrew
wrong side of a Brilliance in that one
and Luca and Justin are doing suffering
but Luca we think is winning uh before
we do sign off we just want to look once
more at the three remaining games we're
going to start with Mishra he as we
mentioned he's a pawn down Bishops of
opposite colors uh he's suffering yeah
but those Bishops of opposite colors
especially when the pawns are split if
you put the pawn back on G7 or even
better still put the H Pawn back on G7 I
would think that Black's chances are
actually quite
reasonable the split pawns make me think
it's an unlikely draw but even here
after Quincy salmon I I'm just wondering
how it's going to be to me I'm not
stop
I'm not going to be yeah any Queen
traits again if the pawns were on G7
yeah I'm not I'm not winning I think you
have just too many weaknesses as you
already mentioned yeah that that's
that's it uh the Marquee matchup uh we
think well Benjamin's a whole piece
it's great there was this great line
from the Soviet Union
so there was a match for the world
championship between Michael potvinak
and Michael Tall
and you know here in the west we had
this idea that the totalitarian Society
of the Soviet Union everything was you
know predetermined had been discussed
and approved by the politic Bureau and
stuff like that
absolute garbage so they had the Soviet
Sports magazine and they had some idiot
journalists who didn't know anything
about Chess who was doing the reports
and the game was adjourned And the
reporter had gone to a spectating
Grandmaster and said well what's
happening
and the Grand Master had responded tiles
upon up
in the adjourn position
Paul has the extra Pawn meaning tall is
better but it was reported in the
problem newspaper that in the expert
opinion of yes
I want to say the expert in the new big
event myself Benjamin Bach is a piece
there it goes right all right our expert
opinion is we expect Benjamin to win and
should he win by the way
cement his lead but he kicks down the
arrival yeah he's very close to him
Alpha point exactly and then finally in
the other game we do expect in this game
between Justin and Luca Luca won his
game finally and
that was not a surprise for us I mean
this yeah
yeah he's my teammate
showing your alma mater there okay night
on D5 glorious piece just a glorious
piece
yeah the crucial part in this game you
don't get any perpetuals based on Queen
F6 Luca ran his Apon up the board Justin
said yeah I see what's coming uh good
enough so Luca from the first two games
had that horrible start with the French
defense bounces back a little bit today
Justin's looking for his bounce back
being him it's been marvelous thank you
once again another broadcast four four
games and five more to go right exciting
games too good even the draws that we
saw it was a great chess say it really
was thank you all for joining us
remember we're going to be here each and
every day there's going to be no free
days that players are playing directly
through our broadcast starts at 4 00 PM
a central time here in St Louis yes
[Music]
it's been our pleasure uh tell your
friends where we're hanging out and
we'll see you all tomorrow see you
tomorrow thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited